das ist das Haus in der Ei für die alte
Dorfschule wo im Obergeschoss der
Missbrauch geschah da ich missbraucht
wurde
das ist praktisch einer der ersten Tests
im Keller
macht der Georg mit oder beschwerte sich
wenn er gefesselt ist und
dann kalt abgeduscht wird und dann kann
man ja weitergehen irgendwann
Georg Menne war damals 13 Jahre alt
fotografiert von seinem Peiniger
und das ist der Täter Erich Jansen sieht
sympathisch aus er ist ein
Sexualstraftäter ein Schwein
und katholischer Priester er kann nicht
mehr zur Verantwortung gezogen werden
denn Pfarrer Jansen ist mittlerweile
verstorben
in dieser Kirche im Erzbistum Köln war
Georg Männer Messdiener
mehr als sieben Jahre lang sei er
sexuell missbraucht worden berichtet
Männer
also wir reden jetzt hier davon dass
seit 1973 fast täglich wenn ich in der
Eifel war sich an mir vergangen hat und
das was sie sich praktisch auf Fantasie
mäßig in allen Variationen vorstellen
können ist auch passiert
und die Auswirkungen sind ich habe bis
heute eben eine Behinderung das heißt
also Neurodermitis Migräneanfälle auch
häufig manchmal täglich Georg Männer hat
sich entschlossen zu Klagen gegen das
Erzbistum Köln mit Kardinal Woelki an
der Spitze es ist die erste
Schmerzensgeldklage gegen die deutsche
katholische Kirche sie könnte zum
Präzedenzfall werden mit seinem Anwalt
will Männer 800 5000 Euro erstreiten
die Summe ist im unteren Bereich
Herr Menne ist mindestens 320 mal in
gravierender Weise missbraucht worden
geschändet worden wenn man nur für jeden
Fall
nach den sogenannten
Schmerzensgeldtabellen 50.000 Euro
bemessen würde dann kämen wir wenn wir
das mit 320 multiplizieren auf rund 16
Millionen Euro
bisher hat Männer 25.000 Euro bekommen
die katholische Kirche nennt es
Anerkennung des Leids kein
Schmerzensgeld sondern eine freiwillige
Zahlung so umgeht die Kirche ein
rechtliches Eingeständnis ihrer Schuld
die Deutsche Bischofskonferenz
verteidigt das Verfahren
die katholische Kirche zeigt als einzige
Institution Deutschland
entscheidungssummen für sexuelle
Missbrauch wir haben bisher ungefähr
1.500 Anträge bekommen es sind 33
Millionen Euro ausgezahlt worden da kann
ich nicht erkennen dass wir nichts
zahlen würden ist aber eine Anerkennung
des leid so nennen sie es und keine
Entschädigung kein Schadensersatz warum
nicht ob wir so einen oder so einen es
ist eine materielle Anerkennung das was
den Opfern widerfahren ist muss gut
gemacht werden eine Anerkennung des
Leids ist für mich kein ordentliches
Schmerzensgeld das ist ein Tropfen auf
den heißen Stein
Irland hier hat die katholische Kirche
deutlich höhere Entschädigungen gezahlt
das ehemalige Waisenhaus golden Bridge
in diesem katholischen Heim wurden in
den 70er Jahren kindermisshandelt
Bernadette war damals sechs Jahre alt
absolut from morning to nice etwas es
war die Hölle auf Erden von morgens bis
in die Nacht ein Schreckensregime der
Schmerz geht nie weg sie schlagen Dich
machen aus böser Absicht frühmorgens um
sechs das Licht an und ziehen dich an
den Haaren aus dem Bett wir mussten
arbeiten wie Sklaven noch vor dem
Frühstück Kinder wurden geschlagen wenn
sie ins Bett gemacht haben aus Angst
nach allem was sie am Tag zuvor
durchgemacht hatten
Bernadette zeigt uns Ihre Unterlagen sie
hat eine hohe Entschädigung bekommen
deutlich mehr als die Kirche in
Deutschland zahlt wie viel genau möchte
sie nicht sagen schon Ende der 90er
Jahre habe der irische premier burty ihr
Hörn Druck auf die Kirche gemacht und
der ehemalige Erzbischof von Dublin habe
sich für angemessene Zahlungen
eingesetzt
wir haben sehr sehr viel Geld für
Entschädigungen gezahlt und in keinem
dieser Fälle hat jemand gesagt ihr seid
weit über die Grenze dessen gegangen was
ihr tun solltet
er hat eine Botschaft an die deutschen
Bischöfe und zitiert dazu ein Gleichnis
Jesu aus dem Lukas-Evangelium Kapitel 15
jesus sagt lass 99 zurück und kümmere
dich um den einen der verloren ist
darauf muss die Kirche ihre größte
Anstrengung legen die 99% der anderen
Aufgaben können warten kann kenways
lernt von anderen Ländern wo es
funktioniert hat
in Irland haben Kirche und Staat 1,2
Milliarden Euro Entschädigung gezahlt in
Deutschland sind es bisher gerade 33
Millionen in Irland hat die Kirche
Grundstücke und Immobilien verkauft wie
dieses ehemalige Priesterseminar es ging
für 14 Millionen Euro an die Universität
Dublin
hier stand früher ein arbeitsheim für
Mädchen heute ist es eine Wohnsiedlung
61 Millionen Euro für den
Entschädigungsfonds
ich denke dass die Kirche nicht glaubt
dass sie uns verletzt hat bis sie
richtig zahlen muss und ich glaube dass
wir mit der Kirche zur absolut keiner
Lösung gekommen wären ohne die
Unterstützung der Regierung und ohne den
Druck den der Staat gemacht hat
in Deutschland aber hält sich die
Regierung raus und überlässt es der
Kirche ihre Verbrechen aufzuarbeiten
sehr zum Unmut der Betroffenen
es ist tatsächlich die Aufgabe und die
Verantwortung des Staates dafür zu
sorgen dass der Rechtsstaat hierzu nicht
unter die Räder kommt weil wir haben
tausende von Verbrechen die nicht
geahndet werden wir haben einen
systematisches Verhalten einer
Institution und nichts geschieht
warum weil offensichtlich
auch auf staatlicher Seite im Parlament
zu wenige bereit sind in den Konflikt zu
geben auch in der SPD geführten
Koalition tut sich bisher wenig
Nachfrage beim religionspolitischen
Sprecher bleibt das so
das dauert alles zu lang und mir ist es
auch zu unverbindlich dass da jedes
Bistum macht was es will das kann aus
meiner Sicht nicht so weitergehen der
Staat muss hier die Zügel in die Hand
nehmen wir müssen das stärker zu uns
ziehen wir dürfen die Kirchen und die
anderen betroffenen Institutionen nicht
aus ihrer Verantwortung entlassen und
damit glaube ich können wir ordentlich
Druck machen damit die Menschen zu ihrem
Recht kommen doch das kann dauern reich
genug ist die katholische Kirche
jedenfalls das Erzbistum Köln ist eines
der wohlhabendsten Grundstücke
Immobilien und der Kirchenschatz in den
Gewölbekellern des Kölner Doms gehören
dazu doch den müsste die Kirche nicht
einmal anrühren denn das meiste Geld ist
investiert in Wertpapieren
Finanzexperte und Kirchenkritiker
Matthias krause hat für frontal die
Bilanz des Erzbistums Köln analysiert
der Kurswert der Wertpapiere des
Erzbistums Köln betrug zum
Bilanzstichtag 4,4 Milliarden Euro davon
sollen abgedeckt werden beispielsweise
Pensionsansprüche und die Rücklagen die
als erstes zum Köln bildet
beispielsweise für den Bau Erhalt das
alles zusammen macht 3,3 Milliarden Euro
aus und dann bleiben halt immer noch 1,1
Euro übrig das Geld ist zwar da doch im
Fall Männer könnte das Erzbistum Köln
geltend machen dass die Taten längst
verjährt sein eine heikle Frage für
Erzbischof Woelki er soll als Zeuge
geladen werden Nachfrage bei seinem
Sprecher zum Thema Verjährung kann ich
Ihnen sagen da befinden wir uns mit den
anderen Bistümern die ja auch betroffen
sind das ist ja keine alleinige Sache
für das Erzbistum Köln und mit der
Deutschen Bischofskonferenz im engen
Austausch eine solitäre Entscheidung des
Erzbistums Köln sitzt da sicher nicht
geben können
haben Sie Verständnis für die Forderung
von Herrn Männer oder finden Sie in
gierig
was ich finde ist da völlig unerheblich
aber dass man das man versucht
also die Frage kann ich Ihnen nicht
beantworten das muss jeder für sich
selber entscheiden ob das also gierig
ist nun ist ein hartes Wort
Georg Menne geht es nicht nur um Geld es
geht ihm um viel mehr es ist die
Gerechtigkeit ich fordere von dieser
Institution der Kirche Gerechtigkeit
dass sie Verantwortung übernimmt
Anfang Dezember beginnt der Prozess
Menne gegen das Erzbistum Köln dann wird
sich zeigen ob die katholische Kirche
ihrer Verantwortung gerecht wird